und das ist nicht weniger als der
nächste skandal im britischen königshaus
geld das stinkt aber ganz gewaltig prinz
charles hat sich in die tasche gesteckt
für seine wohltätigkeitsorganisation
1,19 millionen euro eine spende und zwar
von verwandten von halbbrüdern von ja
ossama bin laden eine millionenspende an
das britische königshaus von verwandten
von ihm dem einstigen ober terrorführer
des mannes der für die gräueltaten des
11 septembers so wesentlich
verantwortlich ist im jahr 2013 soll
sich prinz charles mit einem der brüder
bakker bin laden in seiner londoner
residenz getroffen haben das geld hat
der könig von england in spe angenommen
obwohl seine berater ihn aufgefordert
haben genau das nicht zu tun also ein
neuer skandal diesmal geht es um
gewaltig stinken das geld dort im
britischen königshaus
[Musik]